got some good news out of the uk i think  we just got some video into the newsroom  of the queen there she is there she is  she hasn't been well and we have not  seen her in a while so this is very good  news indeed yeah reports have been that  she'd hurt her back  she had a back back sprain she looks way  better than when my sciatica is acting  up so i don't know okay great that's  windsor castle uh and she she looks like  listen just the fact that she's standing  up and she's greeting visitors  she's 95 years old as we all know yes  she had to cancel the last couple of  appearances she was hospitalized a month  right so to see her up and about is a  really good thing nobody is and in fact  they're showing us that video i think  it's a big deal the fact that they're  showing us the video is like nothing to  see here  she's good her majesty's good doing well  exactly